so after the texas shooting  ted cruz and others wouldn't stop  talking about doors the problem isn't  guns it's doors have one door into and  out of the school and have that one door  armed police officers at that door and  now we have a mass shooting outdoors  where there are no doors and suddenly  doors aren't the issue now the problem  is ladders well it's a fire escape that  the shooter used to get up on the roof  what do you do about that you need fire  escapes in fact just about every idea  republicans have would go against local  fire codes no doors one door locked  doors no fire escapes secured fire  escapes  what about just dealing with the guns